tensions are escalating between two of
the biggest powers in the Middle East
Saudi Arabia and Iran Saudi Arabia
ordered all citizens to leave Lebanon
after the country's prime minister
mysteriously announced he's stepping
down he made that announcement while in
Saudi Arabia Lebanon is currently on the
front lines of a regional conflict
between Saudi Arabia and Iran Secretary
of State Rex Tillerson said the United
States has been assured that Prime
Minister Saad Hariri is not being held
against his will
Holly Williams is in Istanbul Turkey
Holly good morning good morning Saad al
Hariri resigns suddenly as Lebanon's
prime minister on Saturday while
visiting Saudi Arabia and in very
mysterious circumstances there have been
reports that Saudi Arabian authorities
forced him to quit his job and he's
being held under house arrest those
reports have not been officially
confirmed and the Saudis insists that
al-hariri is a free man we simply do not
know exactly what's happened but the
reason this matters is that Saudi Arabia
and Iran are fighting a proxy war in the
Middle East vying for power in countries
including Syria and Yemen Iran has
enormous influence in new in Lebanon via
Hezbollah a group the u.s. considers a
terrorist organization Saudi Arabia
could now be challenging that influence
and there are fears it'll spark a
conflict in Lebanon some in this part of
the world believe that Saudi Arabia has
been emboldened by support from
President Trump who recently tweeted
great confidence in the Saudi leadership
all of this comes against the backdrop
of the rise to power of Saudi Arabia's
Crown Prince Mohammed bin Salman who at
just 32 years old is consolidating power
in his hands
including with an anti-corruption
campaign that's already seen more than
200 people detained reportedly including
several members of the royal family
Gael all right thank you very much Holly
Williams